let's go next to our caller from the
eight five zero area code who's calling
today from eight
five zero uh hi david this is luke
luke what can i do for you uh my
question is about uh
bill clinton's speech last night from
the uh democratic national convention
yes a couple nights ago because this is
friday remember
oh gotcha gotcha i was wondering what
you thought about the lighting
of the room you know the lighting was
amazing actually i mentioned this during
the live stream
it was some of the most pristine
lighting that i've seen
and it almost looked green screen like
they got it wasn't head on right one
side of his face
was just just softly brighter than the
other side
it had depth it had size i mean it was
you know the gaffers
and the grips deserve a round of
congratulations bill
bill clinton's lighting was amazing
awesome a quick question and a comment
too if you don't mind sure
okay um i was turned off to
politics when the whole merrick garland
thing happened in the last year of uh
obama's presidency right and um
i was thrown back in once with the rise
of trump like it's
even surreal to this day so i've been
looking for
sort of political commentators who are
well reasoned in their arguments uh
they're not tied down to like tribalism
or anything like that um
uh very fair and reasonable political
commentators i
lean less personally but um that's what
i'm looking for
your appearances on the joe rogan
podcast
uh brought me to you and um i was
wondering if you can recommend
um anyone who sort of meets that
criteria that you do
uh this sort of uh well-reasoned
eloquent
um uh political commentators
i i've been recently put on to um i
think his name is uh
uh destiny um oh you mean um
you mean stephen kenneth destiny bonnell
the second
ah there we go but um uh
him you is there anyone else you can
recommend because i'm fairly new to
your show and uh your youtube channel
and stuff like that
you know it's really just me i can't i
can really just recommend more of my own
show
unfortunately i could i wouldn't no i
mean listen here's the thing
to be honest i'm the wrong person to ask
because i don't even i barely know who's
out there like there's a bunch of people
who are my friends who do this stuff but
i'm actually
i was talking to uh lance of the serfs
recently
he knows the landscape of the
commentators on left and right so we're
thinking of doing a collaboration soon
where he's sort of going to expose me to
the good and bad including the
underbelly of
right wing commentary and stuff like
that i really would not be able to say
there's so many people out there now
doing their thing
but i just don't do any watching of
content like mine as a personal i just
get enough of this stuff where i want to
disconnect and i don't i watch
you know chess gardening instruction on
youtube i just really don't know i don't
know
awesome all right well thanks anyway but
um just one last comment if you don't
mind
yeah uh your appearances on the
i think his name is jessie lee peterson
yes that's gotta be
the funniest stuff i've ever seen in my
life thank you
thank you i'm i would some day after the
pandemic hopefully i can be back on with
him
it would be incredible uh thanks for
taking my call david all right my friend
thank you i appreciate it uh
great to hear from luke there um that is
going to do it for calls today
much better sound today during the calls
we will take calls again